eight months into this conflict launched
by Russia and moscow's forces continue
to fight to hold on to their illegally
occupied territories in southern Ukraine
all across the front line at the moment
the skies are gray it's raining and
there is increasing mud which is
affecting both ground and air operations
but troops remain locked in struggle
across the whole front line
in the East Ukraine remains very focused
on capturing areas of Northern New
Hampshire blast building on its
successful offensive last month where
with lightning speed they displaced
Russian forces from much of the area
that is slower going but it threatens
Russian supply lines in this area
further south Russia is still
maintaining one offensive North of
dunnet city this is largely symbolic and
is led by private military companies
seeking to prove their Worth to the
Kremlin but so far with comparatively
few gains
in the center of the front zapparesia
remains comparatively uneasy on both
sides but there's little movement this
is an area though where Ukraine May yet
have an advantage in pushing South
towards Russian forces especially if
Ukraine can mobilize more forces in the
coming weeks
but it's the Western end of the line
around the city of her son that remains
the most interest and has been the most
covered by the Ukrainian Ministry of
defense today
if we zoom in on the city you can see
the issues facing both sides as we
potentially approach a more important
stage of conflict here for Russia this
was once the high water marks towards
the cities of michalev and Odessa now it
is desperately hard to defend with a
river at their back troops on the wrong
side of the river facing extensive
disruption from Ukrainian forces and you
can see how much Ukraine did manage to
capture back in the last month
at present the Russians have fallen back
to new lines and it looks that they are
set to defend the city despite moving
out potentially many civilians reports
unclear but it certainly seems that more
soldiers have been moved in including
newly mobilized conscripts
it therefore suggests that Russia will
try to fight for this area and that will
pose a challenge for Ukraine
the city itself very hard to take and
the biggest objective yet approached by
Ukrainian forces we remember what Mario
Paul looked like the ukrainians will not
want to go through such an experience
and instead will most likely try and
wear down the Russians break their
supplies break their morale prevent
their withdrawal across the river and
try and win in that fashion but it will
not be quick